EASTERN UKRAINIAN TOWN TO FIND
MORE EVIDENCE OF RUSSIA'S
COLD-BLOODED TORTURE TACTICS.
>> Reporter: THERE'S NO RESPITE
OR VICTORY HERE.
A BATTLE STILL SHAKING THE
QUESTION.
THIS OCCUPATION SLOGAN, WE ARE
ONE PEOPLE WITH RUSSIA, SEEMS
COMIC.
NOW THE UKRAINIANS HAVE CHASED
THE RUSSIANS ACROSS THE BRIDGE
AND FURTHER SOUTH.
A SHELL HAS LANDED UNDER 100
METERS FROM US.
ANOTHER SWIFTLY FOLLOWS.
IT'S UNLIKELY MOSCOW CAN RETAKE
PLACES LOST IN THE PAST WEEKS.
SO THIS IS ABOUT VENGEANCE AND
SPITE.
THIS PRISONER, THIS CLAIMED TO
BE LOCAL BUT THEY THINK HE'S A
RUSSIAN SOLDIER DESERTING OR
LEFT BEHIND.
WHAT ELSE MOSCOW LEFT BEHIND IS
FAR UGLIER.
THESE TINY ROOMS IN THEIR
DETENTION CENTER WHERE AS MANY
AS 400 PRISONERS WERE HELD AT
ONE TIME WE WERE TOLD.
EIGHT OR NINE PRISONERS PER
CELL.
BOOBY TRAPS NOW IN THEIR PLACE,
A WARNING WRITTEN NEXT TO THIS
ROOM.
>> SO HE'S WRITING GRENADE THERE
ON THE WALL.
AS THEY MOVE THROUGH THESE
CELLS, THEY'RE FINDING BOOBY
TRAPS LEFT, IT SEEMS, BY THE
OCCUPYING FORCES.
THAT ONE IN THERE, A GRENADE
LEFT UNDER A TRAY OF HALF-EATEN
FOOD.
AND IT JUST SHOWS YOU THE
HAZARDS THAT ORDINARY PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO FIND COMING BACK.
A PLACE LIKE THIS, SURE, USED AS
A KEY DETENTION CENTER BY THE
RUSSIANS, BUT ACROSS THIS TOWN,
THE DAMAGE IS EXTRAORDINARY BUT
ALSO TOO IS THE RISK OF
UNEXPLODED ORDNANCE AND BOOBY
TRAPS.
THEY'RE DISCOVERING TWO OTHER
SCARS FROM TORTURE.
HE SAYS HE WAS IMPRISONED ABOUT
A MONTH AGO AS HE WAS ONCE A
COOK IN THE ARMY.
[ SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH ]
>> Reporter: THE TELEPHONE WAS
AN OLD WIND-UP MODEL USED TO
SEND ELECTRIC SHOCKS INTO HIM.
HE THINKS HIS INTERROGATOR WAS
EXPERIENCED FROM THE RUSSIAN
SECURITY SERVICES.
>> Reporter: THEY ASKED HIM WHO
HE WAS IN TOUCH WITH FROM THE
ARMY.
THE RUSSIANS BURNED THEIR
INTERROGATION RECORDS HURRIEDLY.
[ SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH ]
>> Reporter: ELSEWHERE, SIGNS OF
A MINDSET FUELING THE RUSSIAN
INVASION.
THEY FOUND TIME TO PAINT THIS
MURAL.
A RUSSIAN SOLDIER, YOU SEE THE Z
ON HIS ARM, NEXT TO A PENSIONER
AND THE FLAG OF THE FORMER
SOVIET EMPIRE, BURNISHED IN
FLAMES.
PAUSE A MOMENT HERE IN THE
BLOODSHED AND RUIN AND CONSIDER
HOW TRULY ODD THIS IS.
THEY WERE ONLY HERE A MATTER OF
MONTHS, YET SO SPEEDILY TATTOOED
THIS BUILDING WITH THEIR
MACHINERY OF PAIN.
SO MUCH HERE CLEARLY BEYOND USE.
SO FEW LOCALS HUDDLE IN ITS
EMPTY HUSK.
WINNING DOES NOT HEAL THE
WOUNDS, JUST GIVES THEM ENOUGH
TIME TO FEEL THEM.
JAKE, OVER THE WEEKEND UKRAINE
SAID THEY FOUND TEN TORTURE
CHAMBERS ON THE OUTSKIRT REGIONS
OF KHARKIV, WHERE SIMILAR
TACTICS APPEAR TO HAVE BEEN
USED.
ALSO THERE APPEARS TO BE
CONTINUED ADVANCES OVER THE
EASTERN SIDE OF THAT RIVER.
YOU SAW IN THE PIECE THERE SOUTH
TOWARDS RUSSIAN SUPPORTED AND
OCCUPIED TERRITORIES AND ALSO
TOO NEAR WHERE I'M STANDING
TODAY WE HEARD FROM UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS SAYING THEY HAD
RETAKEN THAT TOWN ENTIRELY.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY DENYING THERE HAD BEEN
A LULL IN OPERATIONS.
THEY'RE LOOKING TO SEE EXACTLY
WHERE THE NEXT FOCUS OF A
COUNTEROFFENSIVE WILL BE, BUT
THE FIGHTING DOES CONTINUE, AS
DOES THIS TERRIFYING TOLL
THEY'RE SEEING OF WHAT
OCCUPATION DID TO ORDINARY
PEOPLE, JAEK.
>> NICK PATON WALSH, THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
LET'S BRING IN UKRAINE'S
PROSECUTOR GENERAL.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US,
FIRST, WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT YOU JUST SAW IN NICK'S
REPORT, ALLEGATIONS OF TORTURE,
TORTURE CHAMBERS.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE?
>> THIS IS WHAT WAS REPORTED
WHEN IT WAS FOUND OF THE THE
MAIN RESPONSE IS THAT WHAT
RUSSIANS DID IN BUCHA AND IRPIN,
THEY PROCEED AND DO THE SAME IN
OTHER PLACES IN UKRAINE.
SO THIS SHOWS A TURN OF RUSSIA'S
BEHAVIOR AND TREATMENT OVER
UKRAINIANS.
SO THE SAME STORIES, THE SAME --
THE SAME, HOW TO SAY IT, THE
SAME TORTURES.
THE SAME RAPES AND THE SAME
PEOPLE KILLED.
>> DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES
TO INVESTIGATE AND DOCUMENT
EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON IN
YOUR COUNTRY?
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE THIS
NEWLY LIBERATED AREA IN THE
KHARKIV REGION AND YOU'LL HAVE
TO HAVE NEW PEOPLE TO DOCUMENT
IT AND INTERVIEW PEOPLE.
DO YOU HAVE EVERYTHING YOU NEED?
>> THIS IS NOW OUR PRIORITY, NOT
ONLY OF THE PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE
BUT ALSO OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENTS THAT SEND INVESTIGATORS.
WE HAVE ORGANIZED OUR WORK IN
CERTAIN MANNER SO WE HAVE
SOMETHING LIKE 28 INVESTIGATIVE
GROUPS, WHERE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATORS, POLICE OFFICERS,
FORENSICS EXPERTS ARE INCLUDED,
AND THEY CAN WORK IN PARALLEL
AND DIFFERENT PLACES.
BECAUSE WHAT WE SAW IN IZIUM IS
MORE MASSIVE BUT THE SAME CASES
ARE IN DIFFERENT TOWNS AND
CITIES OF LIBERATED KHARKIV
REGION.
SO NOW IT'S MORE ORGANIZED THAN
IT WAS BEFORE, BECAUSE BEFORE WE
WERE ALSO SHOCKED AND IT WAS
DIFFICULT TO CONSTRUCT OUR WORK
AT THAT TIME.
NOW IT'S MORE ORGANIZED AND WE
ALSO HAVE -- WE HAVE SUPPORT
FROM OUR INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS.
SOME OF OUR PARTNERS ARE -- WE
ARE IN DISCUSSION THERE, READY
TO SEND ADDITIONALLY THEIR
INVESTIGATORS AND THEIR EXPERTS
TO WORK ON THE GROUND IN KHARKIV
WITH US.
>> SO AN OFFICIAL FROM THE
EUROPEAN UNION IS CALLING FOR A
SPECIAL INTERNATIONAL TRIBUNAL
TO INVESTIGATE THE WAR CRIMES
RUSSIA IS COMMITTING IN UKRAINE.
DO YOU THINK A SPECIAL
INTERNATIONAL TRIBUNAL IS THE
BEST WAY TO HOLD PUTIN AND HIS
ARMED FORCES ACCOUNTABLE?
>> WE THINK IT'S THE ONLY WAY,
SINCE THE CRIME OF AGGRESSION,
WHICH IS THE MOTHER OF ALL OTHER
WAR CRIMES, THE CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY COMMITTED BY RUSSIANS
IN UKRAINE.
SO THE CRIME OF DEPRESSION
COULD NOT BE TRIED BECAUSE OF
LEGAL CONSTRAINTS.
THE ONLY POSSIBLE WAY TO PUNISH
THE CRIME OF AGGRESSION IS A
SPECIAL TRIBUNAL.
SO IT'S NOT ONLY THE POLITICAL
WHEEL OF UKRAINIAN POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP, IT'S THE WILL OF
EVERY UKRAINIAN.
PEOPLE THAT COMMITTED THE CRIME
OF AGGRESSION SHOULD BE
PUNISHED.
>> I WAS IN UKRAINE IN APRIL AND
SAW FIRSTHAND CIVILIAN BUILDINGS
IN ZAPORIZHZHIA THAT HAD BEEN
SHELLED, SO I KNOW THE RUSSIANS
REGULARLY LIE ABOUT THIS AND THE
CRIMES THEY ARE COMMITTING, BUT
I DO WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND BECAUSE
KREMLIN SPOKESMAN DIMITRI PESKOV
SAY THE WAR ALLEGATIONS ARE A
LIE, IT'S THE SAME SCENARIO AS
IN BUCHA.
AGAIN, THEY'RE LYING.
I DON'T BELIEVE THEM.
BUT HOW DO YOU REACH THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
KREMLIN IS CONSTANTLY DENYING
THE FACTS ON THE GROUND AS ARE
REPORTED BY JOURNALISTS AND
DOCUMENTARIANS SEEING THE BODIES
AND TALKING TO THE VICTIMS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE ARE VERY
OPEN.
WE INVITED UP TO A HUNDRED
JOURNALISTS FROM DIFFERENT
MEDIA, INCLUDING INTERNATIONAL
MEDIA, TO COME ON THE GROUND IN
IZUM AND OTHER PLACES IN KHARKIV
TO SEE THEM FIRST WHAT RUSSIA
DID IN UKRAINE.
THE SECOND, I MEAN HOW TO
CAPTURE WAR CRIMINALS.
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT COUNTEROFFENSIVE IS A
CHANCE TO CAPTURE MORE WAR
CRIMINALS THAN WE HAVE NOW IN
OUR POSSESSION.
AND WE KNOW THAT SOME OFFICERS
WERE CAPTURED.
THERE WAS INFORMATION ABOUT A
GENERAL.
IT'S NOT A GENERAL, BUT
LIEUTENANT COLONELS IS THE LEVEL
THAT WE HAVE AT THE MOMENT AS WE
PRIMARILY UNDERSTAND.
SO PRELIMINARY UNDERSTAND AT THE
MOMENT.
BUT WE HAVE A CHANCE WITH THE
SUPPORT OF OUR FRIENDS AND
ALLIES, ESPECIALLY MILITARY
SUPPORT, TO LIBERATE THE
SOUTHERN PART OF UKRAINE.
YOU ARE READY FOR THIS AND OUR
TROOPS, THEIR MORALE IS VERY
HIGH.
THEY ARE READY TO GO.
WE NEED MO